Conquette vient
de rejoindre le groupe des
conservateurs et réformistes
européens à le groupe ecr.
C'est
le même groupe que les Italiens de Georgia Melanie,
la 1ère ministre,
que le pisse, euh polonais. Et puis euh, le fidèche, hein,
le parti nationaliste en droit de Victor Orban.
Ce qui fait que le CR
espère bien devenir la 3e force politique,
euh, ici au Parlement européen. Mais
ce n'est pas le même groupe que le RN qui appartient à
idée, identité et démocratie.
C'est 1 groupe amené à à peser priori beaucoup moins,
euh, ici au Parlement européen.
Quand on parle de l'extrême droite
au Parlement européen,
souvent c'est c'est pour faire référence au groupe idée.
Jusqu'à présent,
il y avait le
principe d'un cordon sanitaire au Parlement européen.
C'est pour ça que le RN, même si est l'AFD en Allemagne,
même si ils ont beaucoup de sièges au sein du groupe ID,
ils sont complètement isolés
parce qu'en fait, ce qui se passe, c'est que
dès qu'ils présentent 1 candidat,
tous les autres parties se ligent contre eux.
Donc c'est 1 peu comme le front républicain en France,
pour dire non,
c'est l'extrême droit.